professor on from a screenwriting
perspective does the writer gain more
authenticity writing about the situation
from the criminals perspective or law
enforcement perspective oh that's a good
one I'm going to reach into my favorite
book Thomas Harris red dragon where he
writes a scene everything's going third
person first person or whatever he's
going along for with it and then he
switches a scene out of nowhere that is
written from you know and there she's
holding the gun and shooting it and is
completely written from it's about the
character that you've been following but
he switches the point of view that's a
writer's job is to make us look at
things differently that's one thing I
try to do with with when I when I teach
forensics to is one of my favorite
scenes is not a crime movie is dead poet
society where he has already stand up on
the on the desk and and look out and get
it at just a completely different view
of the classroom here we're in a
classroom so change your point of view
play with it what works best for you you
may want to write your entire book from
the point of view of the criminal but
you still have to have her your
resolution in your danao manat fun stuff
at the end but that's something that the
Reuter writer has to choose and I would
I want to dictate what to say but i
would i would just advise play with
point of view it's a very very very very
powerful
you